Five four three,
two
zero
fireworks.
Cool.
Nuclear warfare is not a nuking the moon.
It doesn't that sound just plain crazy.
What would happen?
Would we be able to see the blast?
How would we be affected by the followup when we even survive?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we detonated a nuclear bomb on the moon in 1957
the Soviet satellite Sputnik successfully orbiting Earth,
putting Russia ahead in the space race.
Not to be outdone,
the American government decided to nuke the moon.
The U s believed that a lunar explosion visible from Earth with showcase
American firepower and improve morale at home.
How about it would seeing something like this in the sky give you peace of mind.
The most powerful nuclear bomb created,
it has a yield of 50 megatons of TNT,
the equivalent of 3,800 Hiroshima bombs.
Wondering how nuking the moon would affect humanity.
The short answer is this.
It wouldn't.
You're going to need a bigger bomb.
Roughly 10 trillion mega tons of TNT bigger.
An explosion that size would likely push the moon out of Earth's orbit.
Exposing us to meteors affecting our tides while catastrophic Lee affecting our
seasons,
but that's what it for another time.
So while our bomb might not be able to knock the moon off its trajectory,
could our experiment drastically affect it's radiation levels?
That would be a big problem.
Among the many reasons the U s canceled the 1958 plan to nuke the moon,
apart from the worldwide disapproval was the idea that the nuclear followed
would ruin the military's plans to colonize the moon by 1967
but our moon isn't like earth.
It's not protected by an ozone layer,
meaning it's directly exposed to cosmic rays and solar flares.
This results in high levels of space radiation on the moon surface and so much
of it,
the radioactive follow from a single nuclear explosion would hardly make a
difference.
Interestingly,
NASA is still looking for a way around the Moon's radiation problem since it
helps to build and staff a lunar base there in the near future.
If we didn't need it in a new,
on the moon,
the most damage we might do physically is add another crater to its surface,
which is ironic since the moon gets its craters from blocking meter rights
heading for earth.
So maybe we should stop trying to attack it and be grateful for it's defenses
and the seasons and the tides
I made it.
The most damage we might do physically is add another crater to its surface,
which is ironic since the moon gets its craters from blocking meter rights
heading for earth.
So maybe we should stop trying to attack it and be grateful for it's defenses
and the seasons and the tides.